now today's guest is a host of the tim
dillon
show he's one of my favorites to follow
on social media at tim j dillon
on twitter he will re-configure
any stress it is caused to you by social
media
he can do it uh he is a comedian or a
comedian
and he is a man and he is here today
for the second time mr tim dillon
[Music]
[Applause]
dude i love you man i wanted to start by
telling you this oh
i love you bro
[Music]
uh your tweets are some of the best
things that
[Music]
i even it's like literally i'll be just
lying on my sofa and my sofa is getting
bad like myself is starting to really
get that dent yeah it's gotten bad that
crevice i've never had that before yeah
i've had that
yeah well you're a fat guy whatever you
lay on for more than a few months is
just destroyed
yeah it just becomes like it just
becomes you know i've had beds where
they just they just become problems
yeah i've slept on couches yeah it's
problems yeah wow yeah
and what are you is there a way to
refluff them is there a company you guys
use
no you just got to get super firm right
like the mat like
this is my mattress now it's like okay
super firm
cedar so that you get about a year
before you've destroyed it
and then uh and then you gotta get
something new
but yeah i tried to tweet yesterday this
is the closest that i could get to
trying to like kind of imitate you
and it was when this is all over the
dollar will be worth nothing we'll be
using them as taco shells
salsa will be on the black market yeah
that's it's a little bit in your vehicle
you're in the
vicinity yeah of what i did yeah i mean
i started to realize i can't take it if
you get serious too serious in it
it's then you play into the whole like
anarchy of it whereas if you're just
above it and
yeah and it's ridiculous that's amazing
i try to
like i i try to be funny but
every now and then i'm an impulsive
person yeah yeah
so yeah i just don't have a lot of
control
over what happens
so the problem is like i've gotten to
twitter wars with like the ceo of red
mango frozen yogurt
dan kim and i just i'll i'll be laying
there realizing i'm attacking
the ceo of red mango for no reason
really yeah
um it's kind of like your call of duty
almost yeah
yeah it's kind of what it is i just i
just there are some times when i i'll
tweet something and i hit send
and a lot of times i go yeah i should
have done that
shouldn't have done that shouldn't have
said that but it's so great you're like
almost awol can we bring up tim's
twitter
uh yeah it's almost like you've just
gone so awol that it's like
inspiring it's like oh this is what it's
supposed to be yeah
a not real field that like news sources
sight from
it's supposed to be erroneous well
that's the thing like tick-tock like
what's interesting about tick-tock which
i'm not on but like
what's interesting about it is it's just
like people dancing people being silly
there's money to be made but it's like
that even though it's kind of crazy
it makes a lot more sense to me than
like
the social media on facebook where
people have a 300 comment like they're
trying to make a point yeah
they're trying to say something they're
arguing with their uncle
about something and i'm like no this
probably wasn't what it was meant to be
it's supposed to be like dumb i'm online
at chipotle
right somebody's dancing or crazy like
so it feels like maybe social media is
kind of
winding back to a place of absurdity
well i feel like you're
you're kind of leading it but i mean
that's what i feel like when i i'm like
oh
this is what i need to recognize is that
i
is that it's okay like you're like
leading it back to that place of
ridiculousness i mean this is the
stupidest thing
have you seen this floating cinema in
los angeles
with socially distanced boats how much
work is it going to take to deal with it
imagine all the stoned morons crashing
boats
now to see a movie we're all like just
stay home yeah if that's the other
option i'll just stay home
i don't want to get in a boat to go
watch [ __ ] avengers
yeah this is the craziest thing i've
ever seen well someone would dre here's
the thing someone would get out of their
boat to go pee
and drown like the first one yeah i mean
it's just we're going so crazy with this
where we're like inventing things that
there's no need yeah there's no need for
this
nobody needs to see a movie that badly
they go you know what let's just get in
the boat
yeah let's just go to a movie theater in
the ocean
with socially distanced boats i would
almost rather
get the disease and die and go to heaven
yeah or be reincarnated right like take
that chance
be reincarnated and still not get in a
boat to see a movie yes you're like [ __ ]
yes
like yeah this yeah it's almost god it's
so [ __ ] ridiculous
man yeah i mean it's it's bananas i'm
definitely gonna have to go with my
girlfriend
now that's a good point see a lot of
guys and nick is a very susceptible man
yeah i'm gonna say that
i love nick he's got a lady hard worker
you know very inspiring story but
yes he's the kind of guy you know he's
very japanese like if there's a puddle
he'll stab himself and
bleed out like so his woman can walk
over his back i respect that
he has that very korean style i just
imagine because chicks are going to want
to go to this
yeah and now with everything going on
every time i see a new idea like this i
go
how do rioters burn that down you know
what i mean
yeah like how exactly will that get
torched you know
yeah like every new idea i'm like how
easy is that to just
yeah light that up or what about when
the angry like what about if the gay
fleet from uh
um what's that disney world rider a lot
of like uh um
that disney world ride pirates yeah what
about when they get
because it's a lot of young gay men and
women that work there yeah when they say
we're going to attack yeah we've had
enough of this where do they go yeah
they go to the
the the boat movie theater yeah they're
going to pull up in their boats they're
gonna pull up
yeah if if pirates of the caribbean
disgruntled people
attacked that that would be the only
reason i'd want that to exist
just so it could get invaded and
attacked by angry gay
pirates of the caribbean because you
gotta you gotta be angry that that's
your gig
yeah yeah oh yeah you got it you can't
be thrilled about that
now what about i saw recently um
but yeah if you don't follow tin dylan
what is your what is your twitter tim j
dillon it is
it's the it's like this weird canal
through all of the [ __ ] that is
some moments it's so left some moments
it's so right yeah it's just
yeah god it is good man it's a little
ridiculous
yeah and but just you have to stick with
it man because
you have to believe like i was just
talking to an agent just put up cat like
i just put up the photo of the cat
this is a cat that's not my cat but the
the running joke is that this cat is a
uh is a is a
is like a um a radical
and uh he constantly threatens like
nancy pelosi and he's constantly
impressed
like they constantly keep putting him in
jail and he keeps claiming that they're
jokes
so i just keep putting them up and then
like people will comment like some guy
will be like what's with its teeth and
then
some personal comment under that like
why are you talking [ __ ] about a cat's
looks and i'm like we're off to the
races like already we're off to the
races
it's just a fun my mother's
schizophrenic and i imagine my twitter
is her brain
oh it's beautiful yeah that's kind of
what i imagine my twitter is is like my
mom yeah yeah and this is dubbed in this
cat this isn't a real cat no he's real
he's oscar
okay he lives in west hollywood he's my
friend's cat oh yeah i just go over and
i grab them and they photoshop
these pictures yeah so they just
photoshop them into like
so like yeah it's just oh do the brad
pitt one that's a fun one
he's real he's a demon of a cat but
i love it yeah and he's so like he's
almost so you like he's there
he's disinterested but he's also willing
to
just like get wild in a moment's notice
yeah i mean that's kind of what he's
about
yeah but that's what i that's how i use
twitter is just like
um to just kind of be sometimes i make a
good point but
most of the time i don't yeah and most
of the time it's just me being
ridiculous
but you're so without what i like i
guess is you you're fearless about it
yeah like something happened to me where
i got f i guess i don't know if i got
fearful or i just
i think sometimes i get too like i'm i'm
too real about stuff sometimes so it's
like
right i'm gonna just end up like just in
a bad space you know i'm gonna end up
fighting with jamily hill you know
yeah yeah right i look at it as like
if if i said something and then jamelli
hill said something to me
you win i would tweet her the photo of
the cat
right like i would be like it's like oh
if you want to come into this world
right if you want to take this willy
wonka boat ride yeah through the
craziness
because i'm like this is not a good
place to have a conversation right
and anyone should know that everybody
should know that and everyone should
treat it accordingly
and just be ridiculous i get it
people are trying to hustle make money
and whatever but i'm like if you get mad
at me i mean i put a
mega mccain wig on i dress up like a
chronicle i saw that crazy thing that
was good and it's like if you
get mad at that guy you're you're you're
at fault
yeah yeah what um what about the
hollywood sign getting taken down you
see can you pull that up do you mind
nick
did you see uh people talking about that
because obviously you know there's a lot
of been a lot of stuff people taking
down monuments you know
yeah yeah confederate flag people are
taking down you know i think the
cleveland indians just announced today
they're going to change their name
um do you want me to look that up yeah
maybe both of you can i know you only
have two hands but uh
but i thought about so then part of me
like because i get a little bit angry
sometimes about like because confederate
flag i learned it from
dukes of hazard right right and that's
you like you have a whole different uh
understanding of it because you're a
southern guy
right i would just see it like now if
somebody rode by with a corr
like if somebody yelled the n word right
and was waving it right i'm like
wrong yeah that's a bad guy but
but i just start to worry just when does
it end you know like when does it well
i think a lot of people think that
because a lot of people are like
at a certain point if you go through
history
oh yeah nobody's clean no nobody
nobody's clean so do you just
i mean every movie everything so do you
just get rid of everything do you
destroy everything and then you start
burning books and then you start
you're just heading that stage like i
don't really care about confederate
monuments but it's like
then it's like well let's get rid of uh
you know washington
right lincoln let's get rid of mount
rushmore it's like where does it end
and the other question nobody asks what
do you replace that with
right what are we replacing it with
right because you're going to lose a lot
of branding like even like the
university george washington university
right
like they've been thinking like okay do
we have to change has been like
yeah they just change it to gw and
nobody it's enough they'll be like yeah
it's gw
it's like kfc when they were like not
using chicken
yeah it's kfc you're like yeah but what
does that c stand for
they're like i don't know something
crunchy we don't know what it is
yeah it's just like i can't imagine
that anyone really cares cares that's
the thing that anybody
really cares because we grew up going
like we would go from mardi gras we
would go by the um
we would go by the everybody would meet
at the robert e lee statue in new
orleans right right
and everybody would meet there black
white right that's all we had we had a
little bit of like
i guess maybe mexican or chinese like
kind of like one person might have been
a pacific islander
yeah something yeah gotcha like like i
grew up in a town we had a group called
wham whites against mexicans right
yeah and we didn't have any mexicans so
they would always is that a musical
group
no this is not okay this is more of like
get the torch
yeah yeah just like a budget antifa you
know like antifa but that had to be home
by 6 p.m for dinner
gotcha okay and then and it was only
three guys in it
right and um and then they like kind of
attacked a chinese like semi-chinese kid
once like there was no
real follow-through you know but is it
because they couldn't find a mexican
yeah there was no let's just get let's
just get this guy he's
semi-changed totally yeah yeah oh my
brother it's the best we're gonna do we
just gotta
we gotta show people about it and
there's no mexicans around
but this guy looked half chinese yeah so
he's getting it yeah look
we drew it on our binders during lunch
this [ __ ] is real now yeah we gotta move
forward
yeah wow but yeah just start so then i
start to think okay well
yeah you tear it down but then here's
what i start to worry about is
say in certain uh in certain cities and
whether they be southern really or
anywhere because some of it starts to
branch out now to like oh well thomas
jefferson had slaves and
this person dated a black woman who was
underage and just different things where
it just keeps escalating
and it's like when does like at a
certain point
um yeah like you're saying it's going to
hit everybody but then the people who
live in those places
right who associate with that history
and don't associate it with it racially
right like and i know this is just a
white perspective but those people are
going to be like i don't want to live in
a place where
now the street that i'm on has been
changed like it's also like why are we
ignoring history why are we trying to
get rid of it
right why not just learn from it why not
appreciate it why not look at the statue
and go
yeah that guy did some [ __ ] like why
are statues only of good people
number one like the idea that every
statue it doesn't mean that i never look
at a statue and go that was a great guy
that guy was great i bet he was great i
never have ever looked at his stature
and went
i should think like him yeah yeah i look
at his statue and go that guy did
something maybe good maybe very bad
he might have been very bad but it was
significant
that's what a statue is it's about
significance it's not about moral purity
right that was a guy was a role player
he like throw up a carmelo anthony
somewhere yeah you know what i'm saying
like
right he kind of he like people are 50
50 on if he's really that helpful to a
team
right you know right right but i i've
never looked at a statue
i don't know who we're infantilizing
people
yeah we're treating them like children
we're telling them oh if you walk by a
statue
you're going to automatically uh look at
that statue or that person in reverence
yeah that's not what does anyone care
you know they go let's take down the
christopher columbus statue in the
middle of columbus circle new york city
no one knows who that is right the kids
don't know who it is they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't give up they're on their
phone they don't even look at the statue
so the idea that like columbus uh it's
about
you know columbus is reinforcing
imperialism and genocide
no one cares nobody knows who he is
well then it's like should you take down
like because there's you know a lot of
artwork and i'm
i don't know if there's monuments but of
like slave
probably like arriving in like
charleston like slave ships and stuff
that did
so then it's like well if you're a white
person you don't want to remember that
all the time
so it's like but you should have to look
at it you should have to be like man
wow a lot of this town was built by
slave labor
right that to me makes sense like you
have those monuments
and you're like i can't forget this
history
right you know but if i i feel like if
you're going to apply apply it to
everything it's just like
you know because some people might think
man i didn't do this
right why do i have to be reminded of it
all the time yeah but
yeah because that's applying the same
psychology i feel like to the ones where
you're applying it to
you know like george washington or
robert e lee you know like yeah
or just put on robert lee's thing this
guy got second place in the civil war
that's right this guy was [ __ ] up
yeah this guy is [ __ ] up and aren't we
all and aren't we all
um or yeah i think it's it the people
that really are advocating
that they take down everything are
people that just
want to completely remake or reimagine
america
yeah so they start with the iconography
of it and they start with like
the statues and everything and it's like
we can all agree that america has some
deep deep flaws it should be corrected
but
i don't think anybody's or a lot of
people are not going to be on board
for the new version of america that a
lot of these people want
right nobody wants that where you don't
have any freedom
well nobody really wants that and i
think that's what
this kind of america that they envision
is an america where
everybody is constantly policing
themselves and their speech and your
being
their surveillance uh of everything you
write
and say and it's just weird like you
want to rat on people and if
i remember when gronin started people
were like yo
go go call this number if these kids
don't have masks i'm like what
yeah i don't want to be a rat dude
there's a kid skateboarding i'm
supposed to call a number and be like
yeah i see a kid without a mess go get
him
yeah todd has it yeah yeah i don't want
to inform on people
i just that to me that whole world is
not
i don't like that world i don't want to
live in that world i'd rather live in
the world
with some of the problems in this
orwellian
nightmarish world where like people are
like i can't say anything
i'm afraid to have an opinion i'm afraid
to meet somebody at this corner because
both of the people it's named after were
racist yeah it's just like what are we
doing
because then it's just people wandering
around yeah unable to meet at certain
intersections they don't know what it
means or the weird guy who will only
meet in front of the robert e lee statue
he's like we're meeting in front of lee
you want to date me we meet in front of
lee
and that's it we always meet in front of
a confederate monument
yeah yeah it's weird man or just yeah or
maybe like you add
to them now i think that would be even a
better idea yeah
add to the monuments yeah you know yeah
how are you kicking them in the face yes
dude how are you telling me doing a
scissor kick right something sitting on
the front of the horse
why not it's funny i think it's like in
the absence of real solutions people are
like hey let's just take the statue down
yeah you know it's like how about
stopping police shooting black people
yeah uh let's take the statue down let's
just
how about stopping uh some of the the
issues in hollywood people getting
abused or whatever
let's just take the sign down yeah let's
just take the sign down
that'll cure everything but see that's
where it's like that to me would really
make hollywood i think if you took the
sign down yeah
then hollywood's going to be like well
what do we have then right
what what was the movement to take the
hollywood sign down i haven't heard
about that well
i'm sorry nick headed up a second ago
and i uh
wait a minute can you go back to indiana
governor wait a minute hold on go back
to the
indiana governor says all people over
the age of aids will face wait a minute
class this is great
what was that indiana governor says all
people over the age of eight
will face a face mask there are some
nine year olds that are gonna get thrown
into paddy wagons and that in indiana
oh what are you ten yeah get your mask
on
yeah i love kids learning about
government at nine
you know being like oh i lose my
freedoms at nine
so different dude damn and are these
kids
and i just wonder if the masks
how are they gonna develop their
their world it's going to be
underdeveloped yeah i mean
we're heading under yeah developed
i mean we're heading to a scary place
i'm all for like yeah where the mask
keeps
people safe whatever but i just think
there's something hilarious
about the the like this weird age of
like eight
yeah this like meaningless distance
that's when they know eight
yeah it's like if you're nine you better
have your [ __ ] together yeah
you better have your [ __ ] together at
nine it's almost like the eighteen huh
it's like the freaking age
yeah yeah you're gonna serve in a war uh
the hollywood sign it says right here
the hollywood sign
um has been through some stuff it said
on there
did you have an art was there something
i have there was one tweet it
it that's it thirty three likes you the
blue checkmark
people that are on the right they're
going if you're gonna take down
jefferson washington we're gonna take
down a hollywood site so this is what
happens
it just becomes and that makes sure
i get it and that's when you start to
look because that's what i feel like
it's like
you have to that's smart ball to me
yeah if you are on the right or if you
are
it's like well what about the the you
know the obvious
you know the the me too so what about
all the [ __ ] that goes on in hollywood
100 percent
deviant place 100 it's awesome 100 yeah
but it's risque
yeah there's lots of long
established problems yeah power dynamic
issues here oh yeah um
but the whole thing is like i when jenny
slate uh apologized for doing the voice
of a mixed race character on big mouth
yeah i saw that i did this whole thing
on my podcast as a joke where i was like
it's not enough that she's stepping down
because her apology is very creepy right
people i was like why why does she jenny
slate from everything i know about her
is probably not like a racist right
why is she coming out to like confess
she's like i've erased black people
i cannot believe and it was very weird
like she felt she had to come out and
give this
big explanation it was very weird so i
just said
you know to counter the insanity of that
i said that's not enough she should go
to jail yeah
she should be in jail you know i think
she should go to jail
i saw this every day jenny slate is not
in jail i will speak out
yeah and that's the whole thing because
i said it's not enough so this
is what you kind of do when people go
woke you just
go further right you go you go wide
awoke
yeah yeah you go real yeah wide awake
you go to insomnia yeah you go put her
in jail
yeah put her in check not enough and who
are her parents where they live at where
are they let's share this we're burning
that house down
you raised a racist yeah get them let's
share their information
and what that's supposed to do is make
people go oh yeah this is stupid
but as a matter of fact you get people
on twitter going i don't think she
should go to jail and then some people
go
maybe like a re-education
if you're like yeah maybe like some type
of re-education or something but not
jail next you know she has to take 40
hours of
driving from an african-american
instructor yeah what's great is like i'm
like oh you're almost there like you're
almost at my crazy example
right you're almost at let's put her in
jail yeah that's what you see when you
tweet something crazy
and the responses are like yeah that
might make some sense you're like what
yeah i tweeted the other day and i said
i walked into a grocery store
and i uh they told me to wear a mask i
took it off uh i i didn't have a mask on
i faked a seizure
and then i ran around the store uh uh
called this uh screaming the storm is
coming
and a lot of people on twitter were like
good for you man i wish i could have
seen that
like dead serious like yeah you show
them i'm like yeah i was
i didn't do any of that right but people
are like yeah you show them
people are ready well people are looking
also for
anything that's against the norm so
that's why another reason why i think a
lot of what you say really kind of
stands out like a lot of times because
it's like
also i think you're finding like a seam
of humor in this yeah where sometimes i
forget to like
just be light about like just like joke
around about stuff
well because like you watch these shows
now that are like you know ellen and
fallon they're all at their kitchen
tables
yeah like jimmy kimmel's in his living
room and you're like what's going on
it's weird and then they're interviewing
people
and they're interviewing celebrities and
they're talking about movies coming out
and you're like this is so dystopian
yeah like it's so disconnected from the
reality
that i think people just want anybody
whether you're crazy or not yeah
to talk about something that's actually
going on right
the reality something that's actually
happening
um
do you think that uh would this be a
tough
time you think like because you're
you're a gay man right yeah
so if you're a gay man would it be what
if i said no what if i denied it just
went back
dude she's like absolutely no i'll tell
you this we've been praying i sue
you i sue you i get lawyers i'm like
this is crazy
you know i go to jail i do have new
insurance
i do have new insurance i'd love to use
but is this uh
yeah we've been praying you'll yeah make
it back we're trying
yeah we're trying if hollywood offers me
enough money
i'll do it i'll get a wife i'll get a
fake wife that's a better life
is to have like a fake wife because it's
kind of fun i know dudes who are mad we
all know dudes who are married to
oh yeah and you're like all right but
it's fun because you got a partner in
being a in deceptive
right like i think that's kind of fun
like you and the wife wake up every day
and you're like all right let's go
[ __ ] the world over again yeah let's go
convince the world this thing's real
yeah let's rock that kind of fun that is
that's kind of like mr mrs smith
yeah yeah you're like cia agents you
know and you just got to go out there
and like
hey we got this pretend life let's go
and rock with it
oh yeah i got to be at uh libby's
kindergarten play
love you hun yeah love you come in for
the kiss
do you ever think that there do you ever
meet women that are
close on a like there's almost like a
because sometimes i almost wonder if at
a certain point that gay and straight
will almost be primitive
description might be yeah like i know
some of there's a lot of force stuff
and like you know and people like in
this place now where they don't know or
they
you know and people are just i think sex
will be primitive i think people are on
so many ssris that can't even come and
i mean it can't get dicks hard i mean
just crazy you look at a lot of these
relationships you're like
there's no sex happening these people
just hold each other's hands they softly
cry
they tweet about racism uh they adopt a
dog together
uh but you it's a lot of sexual a lot of
these relationships are
you like a lot of this is probably just
people that have
massive anxiety laying next to each
other having multiple panic attacks
and then someone's strong enough to go
make a cup of
like non-caffeinated tea but if you ever
yeah um during a
tough panic attack but it's almost not
to move yeah okay
it's not the move but no i think you're
right i think but i'm just wondering
if at some point do you think that we
will get
like like i guess there's two things so
one do you ever
meet a woman you're like oh she's almost
there's some b there's something in her
where it's like oh i could almost
date that woman yes because i'm just
curious as to like the
so it's not as a hundred percent like
bla like there's a being inside of
people yeah there are women that i see
that i'm i i'm like maybe i could date
that woman oh that's interesting you
know whitney cummings is a
multi-millionaire i know maybe i could
date her oh yeah you know what i mean
that's there's something there how
do you think she'll ever take her like
just get to the point where she's gotta
she's like i'm taking my tits off this
is
too much you know and i'm i don't know
if she'll do the tits off
that's i think she likes her tits but oh
i know she's like i see her evolving
into a suit
like i could see her she just went
shorter hair yeah i could see her
evolving into somewhat like an
androgynous
power suit where you see her and you're
just kind of afraid
you don't know what's going to happen i
could see her eventually being the
husband of
the doll of herself that she has yes
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying whitney but you
had that yeah no i'm mad like her
marrying the dog yes
marrying the robot as the husband yeah
yeah it could happen
and i can almost see then and that is
when she will sell her greatest show
ever which will be
a new i love lucy yes where she is
is is now kind of identifying as male
and she's
married her robot yeah and if you feel
something they go out into
what do you mean hollywood [ __ ] what is
everyone talking about
and to feel something they go out in her
yard and watch
a couple of her two million dollar
giraffes yeah
you know she will she'll have a safari
before that
yeah i'm waiting for her to go full
surprise because she hated tiger king
she was mad at tiger king
it's like whitney enough but she's gonna
go full safari and then just be like
[ __ ] it
the animals are happier in captivity
yeah and that's
it i want to work at this so far yeah i
want to watch her walk around with a gun
and just like just putting the gun on
the tiger and then he just like
cowers and go man you've made a full 180
yeah from
animal rights advocate to just having
your own safari
she'll become carol baskin yeah she'll
be like these examples
yeah basking right here yeah i mean this
is wild
you know she's got a ranch with with
animals i mean it's wild yeah it's wild
bro it's very yeah it's very white
africa that she's running
in a weird way she told me a story she
kept bringing back this cat
to this animal hospital and she's like
you gotta fix his cat they're like this
cat's trying to die
like he's trying to run away they run
away to die yeah you keep bringing them
in you're [ __ ] them up
right like this poor cat would just
leave someone's house at west hollywood
trying to die
yeah she's driving home by the comedy
store she's picking him up scooping this
[ __ ] up
and bringing him to the animal hospital
they keep going let him die why are you
getting involved
he imagines poor catchers like i just
want to die and this crazy [ __ ] keeps
picking me up in her tesla
yeah and driving me to some hospital
haven't you read the cat's tweet
yeah she's bringing him in she's like
make a robot version of this cat
right now so that he can live forever
the animals was like what she's like
here's a hundred grand i want a robot
cat
in an hour god she's hot though i will
say that
she's genesis that's
[Laughter]
she's an attractive woman
and this is why yeah and this is why i
need help whitney yeah
this is why i need help but i will say
this any time i talk to her she tries to
get me to adopt like a
very rare animal yeah like i don't think
i'm ready for like a
owl or like a shetland pony you know
what i'm saying she's like why don't you
adopt him yeah
wow i live in a one-bedroom apartment i
don't think she's like you know what you
need you
need an owl she's like do you have a
stand-up shower you're not using
yeah yeah i love that she goes to war
with like the animal rights like the
those tiger king people on instagram all
the time yeah
like i'll look at one of their
instagrams there'll be some guy with a
tiger and there's like three comments
down as woody coming like
you know what this is doing to the
animal you know i'm like ah
she's very she's probably making a
statue of her put it up in kalamazoo
she's very she has that ulysses s
grant of animalia kind of yeah she
really wants them to be saved yeah
here's the thing with animals i respect
them i've never given a [ __ ]
right like i've never been like that
deeply
well we used to watch them [ __ ] i
don't want them being tortured but buddy
of mine had a dog he'd take it at the
dog park and he would [ __ ] every dog
and we used to get high when we were
young and go over there and watch it oh
that's fun
do work that's fun yeah that's and then
it was easier to talk to women because
the your dogs
of course they're like oh this guy's
getting into it yeah like look at that
like if this dog can do that what can
this guy do yeah yeah
then you roll up with the erectile
dysfunction which is my big get out of
jail free card
but uh that's why it's hard to meet to a
guy with e.d you know
yeah it's very tough that's tough yet
they're like theo do this i'm like oh
wow i would
love to have done yeah yeah yeah that's
uh not medically possible you have a
doctor
you have a doctor writing you a letter
like like a kid showing up to school
with a doctor's note
you're like yeah i've a doctor's note
that's not even possible
i couldn't have even done that yes sorry
i wish i could have
yeah um but no i just thought that was
interesting yeah if there's like a time
where you can like sometimes even with
women you're like oh that woman i could
there's women out there that i go sure i
think there's certain people that are so
good-looking you're like why not
yeah you know what i mean i'm sure that
happens i'm sure that's
somewhat common is a straight man i
thought about this
is a straight man yeah like
is that the hottest chick that a gay guy
could get
i guess so yeah i mean it depends
because to straight guys there's like
hot there's always like chicks you're
like oh i'm never
i think getting that chick the idea of
anything that's like
you know you're turning a straight guy
yeah people
peop that's like a fantasy that people
have but here's the thing
if you do that are they straight right
that's the other thing
like there's a lot of people out there
they're like yeah i [ __ ] your straight
guy it's like
yeah maybe not maybe not right maybe
they weren't being honest with you
yeah you [ __ ] a liar yeah yeah you
[ __ ] someone who's
claiming to be straight but it's like
yeah i know like i've met guys and
they've been like yeah i've never been
on a date with a guy before i'm like
that's a lie yeah i'm not the guy that
brings you into homosexuality
yeah you've been here yeah i'm not the
gateway drug the guy yeah i'm not
like taylor lautner who's like you're
like let's give it a shot i'm like
you've been down the road a little bit
here
if you're going out with me you've been
down the road you've had some
experiences
you don't go straight to like math you
know
you hung out in some college party
smoked a little weed then lost your job
and decided you know what i want to
taste glass in my lunch
uh yeah dude no there's there's yeah i'm
not the gateway drug
i'm not like the fun party drug yeah no
so i i think that the people
a lot yeah obviously if it's a legit
straight guy where you're like whoa this
guy's legit straight
i think a lot of people are fibbing
right especially in hollywood i think
they're
lying yeah yeah now do you think there's
also now we talk about drug-induced
homosexuality a lot on this podcast sure
okay and do you believe in that um
that is a certain i believe in drug
induced drug addiction
right so i believe that you will do that
i believe that
you will do things to get drugs right
but do you think though that people will
get
[ __ ] up enough that at a certain point
like at 10 o'clock
everybody's having beers and nobody's
gay at
1am when you know somebody has an eight
ball of coke in them
suddenly two guys are gay out of the
group and you're like oh this is
it might be that or it might be two guys
love coke right like
i like in that tiger king thing those
guys weren't gay right
they they went with women right after
that
that was their right yeah he was their
supplier of drugs i see and then after
that they were like i want to [ __ ] women
so they engaged in gay activities to get
drugs
um i don't know i'm not a doctor is it
possible that if you're
doing drugs you start to be like it's
easier to be gay yeah
prop but it's easier to be anything
right when you're on drugs it's easier
to be anything
yeah i used to drink i thought i had
money i didn't have any money
but i was drunk so i thought i was like
oh it's easier to be rich
i'm rich here's money dinner's on me
i was like it's so easy to be rich i
don't have any money then you show up
you go i don't actually have money but
when i'm drunk i
feel like i have money yeah so you act
like you have money
i say yeah so yeah so yeah drug-induced
anything could happen
anything could happen yeah yeah
especially the drugs that they have now
you know like it's like the argument
it's like bath salts
it's like is it easier to fight a pit
bull
when you're on bath salts the answer is
yes
you know it's like would that but that
person probably wasn't
a complete stranger to that type of
behavior right that person's probably
choked a [ __ ] uh jack castle before
yeah that person's probably
dropped kicked a cat or something yeah
and they just got really into like
fighting pits
yeah so maybe for some people it's them
taking on a fear that they didn't know
that they had that might be
it yeah do you think some people view
homosexuality as a fear
yeah sure i think anybody any time you
lose control of your image you're scared
so it when you say uh you're a gay
person when you say
you're a political like if somebody says
i'm a conservative or i'm a liberal or
i'm a socialist or i'm gay
or i'm uh a vegan all of a sudden you
lose control of your image
you lose all of your individuality
because that group is associated with
all kinds of things some of them are
great some of them aren't so the minute
that people view you
as a member of a group ah scary and if
people lose their ability
to like manage their their own image and
then people like oh well you're gay are
you like this
are you gonna act like this or whatever
you you know so i think the fear
is the stigma that's attached to that
group okay so for a while there's a
stigma attached to homosexuality
and and i'm sure there still is in many
parts of the kind and everywhere
so the stigma people fear that
do um are more met do you feel like you
get hit on by more mexican men or
probably on the apps i don't really
answer a lot of the app things but you
can see that though yeah i go like
there's i i do well with like mexicans i
don't go out
with max against that white delight i
bet they hit on yeah
and i'm not racist but i just don't ever
like i never oh really yeah no i just
you know whatever mexican man would be
easy to date kind of you know especially
because there's a language barrier
i've gone out with spanish guys i don't
know actually like like when you say
mexican i think of like a like
some guy like a 5'4 just a guy in a
truck
okay a dude in a truck who doesn't speak
english no i know that's
that's a racist thing but i've never
been out with i think with an official
100 mexican guy
right but i've gone out with guys that
were hispanic but a lot of guys hit on
me that are like
from other parts of the world wow yeah
white people don't are not into it
interesting interesting yeah i think i'm
the symbol of
i think a bigger white guy is a symbol
of prosperity
two other races oh i could see that yeah
so i think i think
uh cause you come yeah they're used to
seeing you come to their country to like
get to date
to date and yeah for sex yeah they're
like oh this
is the guy who comes down for sex
tourism
let's just get him now let's just steal
his wallet now
this is the guy who shows up on the
train and looks around a little bit and
nods and yeah
and taps his cane on the ground i go to
the philippines for the food
so let's just rob him now let's just
take his money now
and he doesn't have to buy the flight
dude that's crazy yeah you almost
you look like yeah like i look like a
guy who
looks like fdr's grandson look like a
guy that would go you know the the eli
roth the hostile that movie
i look like a guy who goes to bratislava
and who wants to just saw people in half
and then just goes back to his bank job
and just sit back on the golf course
just hitting balls
just like yeah i went away there's a
great little spot you can go and just
swap people's limbs off
great tacos yeah good tacos a lot of fun
so i think those people see me and
they're like oh good you know
fat white guy may be prosperous yeah
yeah
that's totally wild yeah you seem like
the guy who made like the monopoly that
old guy like his son like kind of one of
his sons that wants
like a nice guy that didn't earn the
money but somehow i have it
yeah like i didn't earn it i didn't come
up with the thing yeah but like i'm
orville redenbacher's great grandson
and we just made lonnie redenbach lonnie
redenbacher i just made my living
popping corn
and i just sit at the local bar and i'm
real free with my opinions
and i've never earned a dollar in my
life i've never earned an
honest dollar in my life and i'm just
living off popcorn money
from like four generations again oh man
yeah it's great
it's like being on your twitter dude
yeah that's so good that's what i that's
what i look like
yeah but again you can't control your
image right i just look racist
i look like uh you think so yeah i look
like a cop who shot a toddler
oh yeah you know but you look like the
cop they're like whoa how'd this guy get
like this guy he'd get on the force yeah
how do you like if you've been on the
force for eight years it's like oh yeah
he's been on the force for eight years
but if he just got on the force how did
it even happen yeah
how did it even who did he bribe to get
here
listen up guess what we are in times of
disease
times of it's definitely it's that time
during corvid when you'll see somebody
pushing their family down a hill
or across a desert in a in a uh
empty wagon it's different times
and that's why you have to plan ahead
for when the world reopens
you want to have a website that does
work for you and that's what i've got
right now
i recently had a company called modify
which rivals any other option on the web
design market
modify provides a subscription-based
professional web design service for i
mean for the cost of your old cable bill
they cover it all just with a monthly
fee no startup costs
i mean if you go look at theovonne.com
right now it's
it's nice it's comfortable it's suave
it's finesse you know it's a shark but
it's a hamster
you know it's a little bit of everything
and they did that
modify's unbeatable plan is fast
affordable and high quality
with 20 years in the web design game
modify's last website ever plan is the
best option out there
for anyone using the internet to promote
their business
for just 249 a month you will enjoy the
relief
of an easy process quick turnaround and
an
evergreen website modify's plan includes
unlimited updates unlimited support easy
editing tools
and future redesign you will have a
personal
team assigned to handle all of your
account and website
needs they build it they take care of it
it's a one stop shop 249 a month that's
right get yours today
for only 249 dollars a month at
modify.com
theo that's m-o-d-i-p-h-y
dot-com t-h-e-o
these guys don't eff around and that's
the truth
gang on that look the holidays are right
around the corner
and i don't know if that's true but it
could be true
but what is what is right around the
corner and actually
is now is that you gotta
if you have a business online that's
most of the business now business used
to be on main street and now it's on
main screen
it's in front of you and you're gonna
have to be able to ship orders out
quickly people want something they need
it
oh i ordered this i can't wait till till
till september
i need it this month i need it now
well ship station can help with just a
few clicks
you will be managing orders printing
labels
and getting those products out the door
and delivered
in no time no matter where you're
selling amazon
etsy or your own website shipstation
brings all your orders into one simple
interface
you can even handle it right from your
cell phone that's right
now whether you're shipping usps fedex
ups or anything
ship station even amazon fulfillment
ship station can help their interface
handles it all
right there and you can compare and
contrast different companies different
rates
and the times it'll take to get to its
destination
no wonder shipstation is the number one
choice of online sellers
you'll ship more in less time with the
best rates available
and right now we have a code for you use
theo
to get a 60-day free trial that's two
months free of no
hassle stress free shipping
oh i'm shipping and i feel good about it
just visit shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in theo
that's shipstation.com enter
offer code theo to get your 60 day
free trial make things easier on
yourself
ship station make ship happen we've got
a question that came in right here for
you
hey tim how's the dieting going
oh that's the question okay it's a
struggle
it's a challenge you diet i go on and
off it's a struggle and a challenge
because i saw you at a restaurant the
other day remember i saw you
yeah yeah yeah i shouldn't have said
that but no but that's okay i would that
was not a diet
day yeah i try it's hard because guys
like joe rogan have all this discipline
and it's just hard well jaco willing has
a book yeah he's he's got a lot of
discipline too
discipline equals freedom discipline
equals freedom yeah that's what nick
always says to me and i don't do it
but i get it i get it i but also
freedom equals freedom yeah yeah yeah
hey jocko
counterpoint i know that somebody came
up with that title for you at your
publishing company
but counterpoint freedom is also freedom
yeah
what do you do you find sorry what's the
title i have a better argument than that
choco what's the toughest part of
dieting you think for you
not eating yeah
is it a certain time of day i mean
because at eight o'clock i get into this
thing like i deserve a treat
correct that's how i get there's here's
the real problem
there's not too many things in the world
that make you happy right that's just
really what it is
there's not that many things in the
world that make you happy yeah guns
mysteries whatever it is what else
there's not a ton out there
so food is a thing that it just triggers
my response
it's like a drug and it's like my
parents when i was young they just set
me on that course of like oh you did
something good here's ice cream oh wow
you did something good we're going to go
to them and maybe just put it in your
hand or something or what would they do
yeah they would just put a scoop of ice
cream in my hand while i laid in bed
and i would just eat it as i fell asleep
no
they would just take me to eat because
we didn't have that much money
and the only luxury was like let's get a
fun food let's go to pizza it wasn't
like let's take a vacation
right it wasn't like we're buying you a
car oh that's exciting let's go to a
nice dinner
food is the only luxury for people that
don't have a lot of money that's a good
point it's a reality
let's go get pizzas yeah let's go yeah
we couldn't go to like the big water
park let's go to the
yeah yeah let's go cook over by the
river it's cool
your family and i was like let's deep
fry a dog or something you know but like
let's just get a good
let's grill something let's have a
little bit of swan yeah
i had a cousin that ended up working by
the damn golf course and so dude one
time he comes home with two [ __ ]
swans
were they good uh yeah that's not great
they weren't bad
interesting i was young though swan
isn't for a kid schwann's not for
everyone
no it's a majestic creature well it's an
adult something like eating a swan
it's an adult meat yeah it's an adult
meat uh here's a guy obviously he's
looking to date
this guy looks like he's in trouble it
kind of looks like he didn't answer a
contact racing call
he's infected 38 people hey uh mr dillon
uh huge fan mr vaughn
long time long time listener watcher
first time caller and communicator
pardon my back mullet i don't have a top
mullet but i got a little back hair i'm
going to let that heat go
anyway i got a crazy question for mr
dylan what do you think about the
assassin killing himself
that shot the judge's son this just lane
maxwell shit's getting a little trash
yeah it's real creepy yeah so let's get
into this
first let's just establish that epstein
you believe epstein was a pedophile
i'm just saying let's just establish
some great what are you working for
wait a minute hold on what
yes i will take a controversial stance
because i believe epstein is a pedophile
okay you heard it here okay
and you think gees lane was his little
his uh
his his r his runner yeah i think that's
pretty well established i think miss
maxwell was involved in some alert and
inappropriate activities
but as trump would say i wish her well
yeah because that's the way rich people
talk
rich people every now and then rich
people just
become rich and they forget that they
have a job he forgot he was the
president yeah he was
at a golf tee on mar-a-lago in his mind
and he he said what he would have said
to some ceo that was next to me yeah i
wish her well
because that's when you're like yeah my
son he got into it underage real big
problem because i wish him well i wish
him well yeah
just you know watch this drive it's so
different people don't understand also
yeah that rich mindset of it i don't get
it like it's just niceties and
politeness like gizlane got busted
having a couple of chocolates she
shouldn't have had you know yeah they're
just they're just like yeah i wish her
well hey man just
get out of my get out of my world
with your problems i'm rich i want to be
rich jaslane is rich
so i wish her well if just lane wasn't
rich it would be like yeah
burner i don't care put her in a room
and light her up but
cause she's rich i don't want to see a
member of my own class
really bite the bullet so i wish her
well i hope she has to write a long
apology letter to the girls
and they put her back on a boat but yeah
this assassin was super weird
um the judge it was assigned to look
into the money laundering at deutsche
bank so a bunch of investors at george
bank were like hey why are you letting
jeffrey epstein and all these people why
are you tolerating all these high-risk
clients right so a bunch of investors at
deutsche bank got mad at this and
deutsche bank should have just sent out
a letter when shut the [ __ ] up
right we do what we want we're criminals
dummy what do you think goes on here
we launder drug money and everything
else we got narco traffickers human
traffickers shut the [ __ ] up
you didn't care when you returned you
only care because it's the goddamn news
cliff they should like they should like
like hit him with a first name
first name you know listen vance you
know what's going on
shut the [ __ ] up um so
but so there were some banks so there's
some investors i don't know all about it
so there's some investors
yeah and they were all working with the
same a lot of shady people working from
the same bank yeah deutsche bank okay
and they're
deutsche bank's like a lot of their
executives end up killing themselves in
malibu it's super suspect because
people malibu don't kill themselves
they're happy right like they killed
themselves right
so this idea that all these people in
malibu were like i just can't do another
day in the sun
i gotta kill myself deutsche bank is
involved in some weird stuff
so deutsche bank and what is the deutsch
it's what
german okay yeah so they uh
are handling high-risk clients like
jeffrey epstein okay
and a bunch of investors like hey why
are you what are you doing here
why are you tolerating this level of
risk blah blah blah so they bring a
class action suit against twitch bank
a judge gets assigned that suit four
days later
her son and her husband a guy shows up
in a fedex suit her son and her husband
end up getting killed or
her husband's not dead he's critically
wounded her son is dead and then the guy
who does this goes and kills himself
about an hour and a half later
now supposedly this guy this guy named
roy hollander was a men's rights
activist who had actually called an
opiate anthony and like argued with jim
norton
he's like a weird guy and he was the
fedex driver he was just yeah
dressed up in a fedex outfit who's fake
fedex fake fat actor was he interests a
regular vehicle
i imagine yeah oh my god so then he just
didn't give away
himself so what people are what i am a
little suspicious about is i'm like
is this guy actually the guy who did it
is this guy
did he do it but did somebody like put
him up to it right because this
you know this is a crazy coincidence
that
this woman's child is now dead because
that is a crazy way to send a message
right like because you're telling all
the old judges like hey you might want
to gamble with your life we'll kill your
kids
right like we'll just kill everyone you
know like it is a crazy message
um and it makes you think about anytime
somebody kills themselves they can't be
asked any questions
i get real like wait a minute hold on
what happened
so it's entirely possible that this was
some type of threat or
you know a way to intimidate or scare
people that are in the case i don't know
it's also possible that this guy's just
a crazy guy that killed the judge i
don't know but
it's worth looking into have has the
judge responded after the killing
has the judge spoken man suspected
i mean he's tragic 20 year old kid oh
it's heartbreaking
and he was just at home doing what it's
weird that guy's a men's rights activist
he killed two men
i'm like that's makes me start thinking
like wait a minute what
that's odd but it's also interesting a
good place to go look for someone who
would do something like this
is someone who repeatedly calls into a
radio show but here's the thing the
people that want this done know that
right they know that of course they're
like this is where we find crazy people
they know where to get to fund people
yeah
this guy also 20 years ago worked for
crawl securities which is like an
intelligent corporate espionage
intelligence gathering
uh major corporation he worked for a
year in russia
handling uh intelligence gathering for
kroll so it's just odd
very lee harvey oswald yeah it's a very
weird like background for the guy to
have you know
here's a guy right here who has an issue
and this guy
i have a few issues yeah what's going on
my name is miles
tim i saw you at the stress factory in
bridgeport connecticut
and you said that i look like i traffic
children because i was wearing a suit
so two questions one would you like to
retract that statement
and two do you think glenn is going to
make it to trial
i don't yeah number one let me retract
that statement because now you look like
a dirtbag who can't afford anything
uh you should have kept the suit on well
he does have a frisbee collection behind
him yeah
now you look like you now you look like
you traffic pizzas to people's homes for
a living
so that's what you look like now you
look like you're trafficking for papa
john's
trafficking bread sticks to poor people
um uh it will glaine make it to trial i
mean
i mean not if a lot of powerful people
have something to say about it
do you think i mean do you think a lot
of people
really were into this type of thing like
they would fly over there to have sex
i think enough yeah i think enough
people yeah i think it was a way to
blackmail people so powerful people go
over there they do this stuff you get
them on camera
you own them and control them forever
yeah so if you're an intelligence agency
or whatever even you know a billionaire
that wants to control
senators or congressmen or whatever
because you don't want the passing laws
that [ __ ] with your money
it's just it's a foolproof way to be
like yeah oh you're gonna vote that way
how about this and then they go
yeah i guess you're right so in the end
do you think that epstein's biggest
problem was
or not obviously he had a lot of
problems but do you think that one of
the underlying issues of all of his
problems was
more like control it was like how do i
yes it was all about like manipulating
people you're absolutely right it was
how do we control people and epstein was
just
a facilitator for bigger forces that are
looking to control people
wow and that's part of what happens you
know i mean i'm sure listen
there's reasons in hollywood that the
same actors get the same roles
all the time and a lot of them are very
talented but i think a lot of it is that
they have very powerful agents and
people that are able to like
get make things happen right how do you
make things happen you need leverage how
do you get leverage well leverage is
information yeah right it's information
that's
technically kind of what leverage is
it's like i know that's a prime
ingredient yeah
so i mean it's it's it's entirely
possible that like this is just the way
things have been run for so long
and now it's coming to light because you
have the internet and you
have people back then victims couldn't
talk to each other
so one girl that had crazy experience
couldn't email another girl and go hey
did this happen to you
right yeah that's like the only positive
thing from it um
here's a young man right here that has a
question who may have been trafficked
sorry man i should have said tim dillon
theo bond you guys are two of my
all-time favorites i love all your stuff
i check out your podcast
pretty much any chance i get uh i was
gonna ask
uh this can be for both of y'all with
all the craziness going
on uh in hollywood right now
would you guys consider getting a
stunning estate
in the stunning state of kentucky we'd
love to have you
ooh ky famous for his jelly honey ky
would
consider moving anyways you guys keep
rocking
is that an offer yeah i'll move in with
you gang bro your folks feel about that
now this is a very handsome young man
does it make you feel a certain way when
you see this guy
i said i'll move in with him in kentucky
if he wants
that's what he's offering i imagine
that's what this is about uh he also
looks a little bit i want to say
like um kylie jenner here's what's great
about him
he's anonymous looking yeah he has this
weird like
you could just imagine him as kind of
anything david arquette's son
yeah like maybe he's a good-looking
pilot yeah but maybe he's
10 other things so he's got this weird
kind of like
there's nothing distinct about him he's
just a weird like
model type of like look but but kentucky
like a model for kentucky
oh increase kentucky most people have no
face yeah
in kentucky this guy is a damn i mean he
is a
look he's a nine male or female in
kentucky kentucky yeah
kentucky's uh he's a nine yeah uh would
i consider moving
hockey no the answer is the answer is no
when you're not going to get tired
you're going to go to kentucky
no no i'm going to go look past i'm
going to go like yeah i'm going to
respectfully pass
uh but are you thinking of going
anywhere i am
i'm thinking of going i'm going to go
look in nashville i'm uh wow
i just got a plane ticket do you think
everybody's just leaving
you know i don't know man i my biggest
thing starts to be state taxes that's my
biggest
honestly it's money 100 you know nick
this chair squeaks
too um but
um yeah money starts to be the one of
the promises and then also what's
what are you paying towards it's like
yeah if i'm paying taxes
like what is it going towards and then
if everything's shut down dude should i
get my taxes back
good point yeah i don't know i only
moved here but a year ago i've been
coming out here for
two years but i moved here about a year
ago and i'm like
i know i have friends leaving and going
other places but i don't know i feel
i feel kind of like ellie's gonna i
think we're all like thinking that this
is gonna be forever
ah and every decision we're making and
every thought in our mind
is based on the idea that this doesn't
end which could happen and
would be terrifying and probably a whole
host of other problems but doesn't this
end yeah that's true doesn't this end
yeah that's it
doesn't it end and then doesn't things
go back to something resembling what
we're used to and maybe it doesn't but i
mean
if it ends are we going to want to be
somewhere else i don't know maybe we
will
yeah i don't know it's a good question
man that's what yeah yeah
because i start to think yeah i would
like to get in a place that has
probably i mean i'd love to get in a
place where i could save tax money but
then also
there's strength in numbers like it's
nice to be around like people you know
and like
yeah you know to be able to meet up and
chat about stuff so i'll start to wonder
well
what's it it feels like a different life
like it feels like one of those netflix
series where like some somebody moves to
like a small town
yeah you know and they're like i gotta
now meet everybody and like
i don't know i just feel like i just
feel like i don't think anyone has to do
anything drastic just yet
right let's just wait out the year see
if you feel this way in january and you
might
right but i feel like i feel like that's
a good point yeah just wait out the year
it's a bad year
as soon as this all started to happen in
march i said this year's shot
right i just knew it in my head i
mentally said it i'm like this here's
done
we're just losing a year i think it's
going to turn around
in 2021. what are things it might turn
around right after trump loses
immediately
everyone's cured yeah shockingly there's
no new cases and you're like
like yeah every everybody's great do you
think
uh do you think trump will win or lose i
probably lose at the moment
it's he's got it's tough and it goes
moment to moment doesn't it it's moment
to moment it really is debates could
could could make him the favorite again
because biden is not a good debater and
he's kind of mentally not there but i
think trump's fighting a lot of battles
that are losing battles yeah like the
economy is collapsing
this coronavirus was not really handled
well um
he pours like forget politics so i keep
explaining my friends like super pro
trump
i'm like if there was a ceo of a company
and half the people in it thought he was
trying to kill them
even if they were wrong you can't get
rid of half of them
right you got to get rid of him like he
pours gasoline
and like every day whether he's he might
not be trying to kill them but every day
gets in the elevator and he's like
maybe i'll kill you like like
wait he's doing it again he's doing it
and then the other people the company
like
that's the way he is yeah he's joking
that's what he does
yeah it's a joke and they're like no he
said there was poise in the pen he's
gonna stab me they go
will you stop it's amazing how we can't
live in this schizophrenia forever
so many people take everything he says
so so seriously yeah
it's like um and also i think a lot of
people want him to be something that he
isn't a lot of time yeah it's like
a lot of people elected him knowing he
was a cr like
crazy wild odd businessman yeah he's a
con
artist yeah he's the most successful con
artist of all time
which is why there's part of me that
likes him i know he's full of [ __ ] the
people on the right think he was chosen
by jesus
to free every child that's being
trafficked or whatever
the people on the left think he's adolf
hitler the reality is
he's a riverboat casino hustler he's a
huckster
and he's just been able to bluff because
he knows social media
and he knows and i think that's the real
story
that's what makes him more interesting
to me yeah he's the most successful
[ __ ] card shark three-card monty
dealer [ __ ]
slum lord that you've ever known like
he's doing it on the world stage he
doesn't have a clue what he's gonna say
right he just lets it fly yeah he lets
it rip and that character to me
not that he's this omnipotent force of
evil
or that he's uh this amazing angel
the idea that he's just kind of a
regular guy
who's a con makes him more impressive to
me
and it makes the story actually a lot
more interesting oh this
vote if you want a good show if you
don't have cable anymore but you still
want to be a part like if you're able to
have the
separatist and not get it like sometimes
i get my boots in the mud
yeah if you're able to keep your boots
out of the mud there's no greater
show than the show we're watching than
the show we're watching yeah
it's obvious you're gonna be fun i mean
america is gonna give you money
you know like um but i i also think
well i don't know
right now people are getting mailed
money and can't handle it
yeah some people are getting guardian
mailed money home
yeah once a month and they're just and
they just
cannot hack it you
um they gotta go to applebee's it just
licked the floor well there's a thing
i remember when he won which i thought
he was gonna win
yeah to me it became really obvious yeah
i thought so but
when he won i was like holy [ __ ] the
next day and i
i think everybody had this moment
they're like
i could be president yeah well i think
everybody had that moment and then
everybody had
this this very interesting moment too
and it happens
in every thriller in every thriller of
most thrillers there's a scene where the
car is dangling
off the off the mountain right
and everybody's you're kind of in that
moment of being like
what's gonna happen now yeah when's it
gonna fall it's gotta fall right
or does it get pulled back does it get
you know how does it work just did the
mercedes-benz back up in jurassic park
and
you know somehow and the problem is
we've been living in that moment
for four years like that moment of like
tension and anxiety and what happens and
some people are like oh this is fun it's
a movie
and then some people are like no but
they could die and some people like yeah
but they're not real and
some people like no but they are
actually real some of them are real and
you're like good points some of them are
real
so it's just i look at it so differently
everybody's so invested in one side of
the other side
i look at the guy and i'm like nobody's
had a wilder life than this guy
yeah nobody like he might have has one
of the most crazy lives in history
i can't believe that more black men
don't lowkey
think that donald trump is oh they do
because he's like
some people complete like he's a
the g he's like yeah in that regard of
like
money cash hoes men in general i think
because we tend to like
just we're not like i think women might
think about things a little more
right but men might just take something
at face value
and sometimes the stuff he says you just
got [ __ ] hilarious
yeah and you just move on about your day
whereas a woman will be like uh that was
horrible
like he said a horrible thing and he's
our president you're like yeah but he's
it's just funny but also when you grow
up poor especially i mean growing up
poor and white like you never have
any i never thought any politicians were
really much but cl like it always seemed
like
like they never came to our neighborhood
and did anything you know
i remember the richest guy i knew would
drive by our neighborhood he was a
veterinarian and he would throw
dead animals into the ditch outside of
our apartment complex
and i remember we would throw like
carcass that like caught like cossackses
and like
you know goat occipitals and [ __ ] at
each other just you know
and just rattle off you know if you got
a rib cage you would just have unlimited
bullets
from true detective this entire child
but just like
and that was like kind of like he was a
city councilman or something i think and
that was the closest
we ever got to play there was a senator
lived in my account
clearly a mob guy all right his name was
like al d'amato he's like a respected
guy people know he is but he clearly has
a local
goon and he was just like he would just
walk around the san gennaro festival
just like eating this little custard and
like just
drinking booze i'm like this dude
doesn't give a [ __ ] drinking the blood
of his
yeah of his grandparents he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about any of this now he's a nice
guy and my family liked him but it's
like
they don't care he had a poker alliance
let's look at him right here there he is
alfonse
alfonse d'amato yeah he would just walk
around and like you know he'd have like
a little eggplant parmesan he'd be
twirling linguine
yeah and a little uh like a little paper
a little uh plastic cup yeah maybe twirl
the linguine and just walk around eating
it like
you know they'd be playing like when the
moon hits
and i'm like what are the chances this
guy's uh i bet he's pretty swayable
yeah yeah i bet you could put him in a
room hand a little money and
d'amato is chairman of the poker players
alliance
a non-profit organization set up to help
protect and fight for the rights of
poker players in the united states
that's long island that's where it came
from
we protected the pokemon and look at his
dimey
dimes yeah sound like brennan's child
right now but his diamond
dime of a wife yeah look how
he won her in a game yeah
he could have won her from trump here's
here's the interesting thing i think
about trump
i think he's he's a reflection of what
we have become
a country that does shady business right
that we're all on our third wife
right we have a semi-autistic child
everybody has a semi-autistic child
and i don't mean this in any negative
way i just to me he's like
he's the mirror we don't want to see
like yeah
in a lot of ways you know what bothers
him
about really rich people is like what
they will say to country club to each
other privately he'll just go out and
say that to the united nations
and they're like whoa whoa you guys are
trash
you're like you know he's the he's the
dad in your neighborhood who's like this
neighborhood's changing and you're like
shut up dad imagine he now he's the
president
now that guy's a prince now the guy who
sits on his patio
smoking a cigar saying veiled racist
things is now the president of the
united states
it's a problem but it's also the most
predictable thing ever yeah
because we love celebrity we're obsessed
we love the idea of somebody that we
know
he got in the game we know him he has
name recognition we followed him forever
he was a reality tv he was off script
also he came in at a time like
yeah he came in at a time where things
were getting all like everyone is so
tired of this they were boring and they
were good
things were kind of good like even
though things weren't good for
millions of people all we really look at
is like media and everything and obama
was in and everybody was like yeah
things are kind of good
and then we were like wait a minute what
if we just throw this wrecking ball
at like it might just be interesting
again and then we didn't know now we're
just living in the time when we're like
oh we didn't know how interesting it was
gonna get
yeah like we didn't realize how house
fragile i didn't realize
i didn't realize how fragile society was
i didn't realize how many people
were interested ready to just burn down
to trader joe's it's interesting i
didn't realize how many people were like
you know i'm mad about that
let's go burn down to trader joe's well
i had no idea we're going to start to
see
like people putting antifa on their
resumes right
yeah like i was a colonel in antifa you
may remember me
i put it down to trader joe's fairfax i
was look out at that foot locker that
went down
outside of tempe you guys may remember
that but i i get it because
i was under the uh i wasn't the rightful
watch
of zodiac 47 yeah people are
are desperate and people are pissed yeah
and they're just like [ __ ]
it and i get it and like we can work
from home we've got this unique you know
we worked our ass off to get here but
it's just like
i get it because i i have friends that
are like man i don't know what i'm going
to do now
you know like they're like i worked at a
restaurant and made good money work at a
steakhouse
it's shut down and when it's open we can
only fill 30 of the tables i don't know
what i'm going to do and i'm not getting
unemployment anymore because i'm working
but people those people saying people
are still ejaculating
into their girlfriend yeah it's stupid
that's stupid no i'm saying it's just
like
they're still doing that yeah it just we
don't
we don't get it we don't get it we don't
get it yeah and we maybe we never do
how do you think the whole the book the
storybook of humanity kind of ends
do you think we get it look at it you're
looking at i think it ends in a
dystopian
place and what is this it ends like what
does that mean dystopian
utopians like a perfect world dystopians
like a [ __ ] up future
like yeah i think it ends mad max here's
how i kind of internalize it thanks nick
um
i think it's like here's what i think it
is
i think outside there's going to be like
fights and and people be fighting each
other
hopefully they'll be fist fighting each
other inside of an olive garden olive
garden will become
it'll be a place for fighting
government's gonna be like snatching
people off
it's gonna be crazy right and then
you'll be inside your house
with like vr goggles on like doing
tick-tock dances
and outside there's gonna be explosions
and you're just gonna hear gunshots and
then
you just can't hear it because you're in
like this augmented reality world of
like
the whole thing is we just climbed into
the computer yeah when
when this started everybody was just
like well the outside's a problem you're
gonna get sick
somebody's gonna you know oh that's true
now we've all climbed into the computer
i'm in the computer we're just gonna
live there forever
so humanity will it'll just get weirder
and weirder and weirder
to the point where if you're like hey
you wanna go to the park somebody's
gonna be looking you go are you [ __ ]
sick are you a [ __ ] sicko do you know
what's out there
marauding gangs coronaviruses diseases
government agents like it's going to get
pedophilia
yeah but god like like public school
teachers the worst
the lowest of the low and i think tick
tock is a great way to take a glimpse
into the future
because the news will be like
everybody's dying
and then the kids on tick tock are just
like yeah
you know just like this right
just just unbothered just completely
like
like they're teletubbies yeah just like
some kids getting molested and they're
teletubbies they're just dancing on the
screen and they're just like
mouthing the words to songs they didn't
write yeah and they're just
dancing and then and that's kind of the
beginning
of of and then you have this girl who
mouths trump like sarah cooper whatever
her name is
who's whatever talented i'm not cheating
on her but like she just
like trump she like lip syncs trump so
he'll say something and she goes on tick
tock and she's got this massive
following just like lip-syncing trump
so it's gonna be weird it's just like
it's gonna be like
people lip-syncing music or the words of
other people and people can be like
that's funny it's kind of it's starting
to feel strange out there and i think it
just gets weirder and weirder
to the point where we all just want to
live in a video game
because it's more comforting than real
life and what about if semen comes out
of our bodies we just throw it away we
just
it'll come out of your body you'll just
throw it away but i think a lot of it'll
be like
somebody come to collect it it'll be
it'll be sex robots it'll be stim
it'll be weird stimuli it'll be they'll
still be [ __ ] and everything but
it'll be just a weird
it's going to go into you know the way
that these augmented reality games or
virtual reality feels
i think that it's very possible that
like porn gets so [ __ ] powerful and
crazy
way powerful that who knows it's
destroying people's real sex drives
it's destroying people yeah i'm one of
those people yeah it's wild
yeah i'm one of those people man i'm
thinking of yeah
here's a young man that's obviously had
some issues hopefully
i got a quick quandary for you boys
uh for a long time now i've said that uh
timmy dillon
is a top five homosexual man of all time
and i stand by that that's awesome
can either of you name five cooler gay
dudes
than timmy dillon and look first of all
i don't want to say there's a lot of
them i wouldn't want
any of them i'd put you in top 40 men
overall i don't want us to
well that's very i don't want to make
you think that like there's identity
politics within the comedy world
yeah i think it's just fascinating that
you know that i don't know a lot of gay
men that i
that i talk to on a semi-regular basis
right that are out
yeah that's true that's a great question
i would say probably kevin spacey
okay for one well um
what was the question top five top five
guys i think right oh no
gay guys i'll cooler gay guys okay so
you have thrown out kevin's basic
well i here's what i'll say phenomenal
actor okay and they're much more
successful than i am
yeah yeah but when there are issues
oh yeah no he's definitely had some
issues no doubt yeah yeah so
one way to say it but he um but still
one of the most talented actors ever
absolutely just certainly this guy lists
some examples
do we want to we don't yeah let's hear
something sorry that's all good
maybe leonardo da vinci
maybe freddie mercury
but it gets pretty hard after that yeah
i think he's saying because you're so
cool not because gay guys aren't cool no
no
this guy is very sweet um da vinci
mercury dylan
yeah i didn't know leonardo da vinci was
gay but uh i think he was just like
abraham lincoln slept with dude for like
three years that was weird did he yeah
i've been to his childhood home amy
sherman i went to his childhood home
oh my god that's a fun date yeah what a
wild what a wild day that is
when amy and lincoln's childhood home i
take people on pretty bad dates
yeah i really do yeah um let me think of
some really
admirable gay males out there harvey
miller hinchcliffe
okay um brandon chapman i'm kidding i
don't i'm trying to think of like
i don't know like the ones that are
important in history like harvey milk
and people like that
yeah yeah paula poundson almost a pound
stone is it is
is a gay dude that i respect um
uh who's one of my favorite
gay people i don't know if i ever really
think about it like that exactly roy
cohn
trump mentor lawyer for joe mccarthy and
is he a gay man
yeah horrible guy but oh really very
successful and do you know him
no he's died he was like a very
cutthroat
operator of a you know i don't really i
know
enough about him but i don't know too
much about him but he was one of the
first gay guys to be like
i'm also evil are some guests important
do you think that there are i saw i
guess again because gay always
you think happy when you think of gay
you think like oh yeah yeah but it's
there's just as many evil people in the
gay community as there are in the
straight community
sure wow yeah yeah i think it's such a
the distinction is almost i think as we
grow up
it's not going to be like the
distinction of sexuality is going to be
somewhat less oh i feel it i feel it
going there even by one generation it's
almost
insane i mean look at bravo there's a
ton of evil people on bravo
yeah andy cohen like he gets the whole
shows he's like
all right well we're going to put you
all under tremendous emotional financial
strain and maybe someone jumps off a
roof
yeah these people's husbands kill
themselves they i mean
yeah no the dark arts it's definitely
dark arts over there
there's a level of manipulation of thing
like when people when people start to
see other people as just
contestants correct on their in their
life
yeah that's what the real housewives are
be a contestant in your life
sick so yeah you know andy cohen and roy
cohn are two evil
there has to be a dark side to that
there has to be a downside where's the
light side to it
yeah the dark side is the only side that
i see
i mean the light i mean the idea and
those shows are entertaining don't get
me wrong
but that is what why we have trump
right so if you hate trump and you're
watching the real housewives
you are being inconsistent right because
that type of perversion of reality where
we know it's fake but we watch it anyway
that gave us trump that ability
to manipulate situations manufacture
them
uh things that we know are [ __ ] but
we don't care because they're
entertaining
right that's the beginning of trump
well it's interesting too that hollywood
there's not a lot of like hollywood
never stands up and says oh
like they made him a celebrity like i
think trump was always a businessman
people always knew he was this
long-coded businessman and that's why
the people on the right are like [ __ ]
hollywood i'm like your boy
is a hollywood guy he's a uh 15 years he
had one of the top rated shows on tv
he's a hollywood dude but hollywood
never takes any credit for creating them
you know what they refer to as the
monster they never will
it's not interesting bro it's almost
he's just such a successful con
you just got to look back and go this
guy has just
every single opportunity this guy's
ever had to just leverage himself
yeah bite off something more than he
could chew
he figures out a way to make it happen
it's wild
it's insane and he's been able to do it
at the highest level humanly possible
and that's the interesting story but is
there any here's one thing i think we
that we that we romanticize is the
different levels
like there are different levels but i
wonder if the get if that ability ever
maybe it is like poker when you're in
the bigger games it seems
you faded some people fade under that
pressure but some people who
aren't have have very probably not much
empathy here's the thing about trump
there's nothing in that guy's life he
said i can't do
right or i can't be right now that's a
con art i mean that's not
like if you think of the most successful
guy you know you
you know he would still say hey man that
that's not for me
this guy didn't think anything was
beyond the realm of his doing
yeah including leading the free world um
and
part of that is this just the idea that
like no matter what situation i'm in
i'll come out clean
i'll figure it out it's amazing how
it's amazing in some ways it's freaking
admirable yeah the journey of there's a
lot of
to fearlessness yeah the fearlessness is
admirable
there's a lot to look at him and aspire
to in a weird way right
and and and that if we don't have that
conversation we'll never understand why
he's so popular
and if you don't admit that a lot of
what he does and a lot of the people he
calls out whether it's the media
or things that are equally [ __ ] up um
if you don't admit that he's right about
some of that you'll never beat him
right the the reason that he wins is
because you keep saying he's wrong about
everything
right but if you if you seed some ground
to him and go yeah
he made a few good points but
it doesn't matter because he's not
he just can't do the job yeah he's
incapable of doing the actual job
and everyone's forgot that being the
president is a job
like nobody forgets it it's like
managing people inspiring people
taking responsibility not i mean this is
imagine if your
your life was falling apart and you went
your family's life is falling apart
and your father instead of like going
out there trying to get another job is
like blaming your little brother
complaining about you the food your
mother was making being like he's a
scumbag
you know that you know any any anything
i mean this guy's
been outsourcing his room cleaning right
just
he trump is you'd never want a guy like
that as a leader he doesn't take any
responsibility
he's petty he's vindictive he just pits
people against each other
he pours gasoline like if somebody comes
in i've worked in offices somebody comes
in they have a bad day
you try to get them on the right track
yeah you don't
turn around the whole office and go look
at mary she's weak
yeah you can't do that as a leader she
can marry over using her bathroom
privileges
mary's weak she can't handle it you
can't do that as
a lee unless you are and rumor hasn't
she duplicated the key to the battery
you duplicate it but if you're a
fly-by-night con artist you can do that
because
what you're really doing trump just
licenses his name
the only value is in his name and then
people buy he's not this amazing
business guy
i mean what he what he is good at is is
being famous
right and if you're famous you could
just treat people like [ __ ] it doesn't
matter
but i also think though there that he
wants to
be even if the business is if the
business is shady and other people don't
like it
that he applies those same concepts to
a lot of like um things that in america
would seem more like traditional stances
like
okay let's stay a part of the world
health organization and the cdc
because of just how it looks how it
makes the rest of the countries feel
yeah but he's like this organization
hasn't done you know if you look at the
pluses and minuses it hasn't done [ __ ]
they haven't made it and it's not that
everything he does is wrong it's just a
way to do it
right and there's a way to do it that
doesn't feel like we're heading towards
civil war yeah
there's a way you know what i mean like
but he also right i agree
and i'm i'm with you right i think
there's no it's all interesting he's
multinational these these institutions
like the un
the cdc the who they're all corrupt
they're all they all have a litany of
problems
and america does foot the bill for a lot
of things and not get any benefit out of
it right
but there's a way to disentangle
yourself from those systems without
it's just the way you do it oh yeah yeah
it's the way you do it
yeah he his he just doesn't have in his
bedside manner
it's it's for funerals only it's for
funerals
it's a guy like bill burr said it's a
guy that just lived on the top of a
building
yeah his whole life and this is the way
they talk this is the way they talk i
wish her well
weak yeah you know and you that's just
not
i think ideal qualities for a president
it was fun for a while i was on board
and then
trader joe's got burnt down yeah and i
said to myself
like this will not end he won't he won't
act like
he will just keep pouring gasoline on
this until this entire country is at war
with each other
i'm not even a political guy i don't
really give a [ __ ] but i just walk
outside i look around i go this is
probably not good
i see overturned cop cars people are
throwing molotov cocktails i'm like
what happened here we gotta change
course a little bit bring in biden let
him sleep in the chair
let that old [ __ ] die in the chair who
cares weekend at bernie's
who cares just give people health
insurance and go back to it being boring
yeah just let people get an operation
and go back to
let's let entertainers be entertaining
we don't need the president
let's let jimmy fallon be funny again
let's not chain him to a desk and make
him apologize
he did blackface in 96. let's let people
be funny that should be funny
and let's get an old boring person as
the president
what woman is most likely to get busted
for blackface in the future and we don't
know it yet
i i hope it's a fat woman just that's
just because it's funnier to see a fat
lady in blackface it's like oh you you
did this
i could see chelsea handler having done
something at like uh
built her entire career calling a little
mexican guy a nugget
what's nugget close to someone remind me
and he died
same page yeah i just headed up oh there
you go what word is
nugget similar to that's also a
two-syllable word that you wish to
you know and she culture of didn't she
appropriate that rapper guy
dude everything she did was cheap race
jokes and now she's walking around like
she's malcolm x
yeah she thinks she's malcolm x it's
unbelievable i did a whole thing on my
podcast i said i hope she goes and
apologizes for everything america's done
wrong
like she goes to war zones and she goes
hello gaza it's me chelsea yeah that was
a documentary
hello iraq it's me chelsea it's just a
bunch of people sitting there chelsea
handlers walking
walking by dressed in prada why does it
end
it's sometimes it feels like a lot of
women that they have to
take on a political route heavily do you
feel that or no
i think some of it is that i think i see
a lot of guys too and i see a lot yeah
maybe it's just everybody it's
you know what it is man nobody can
understand when it ends nobody can walk
away
nobody can walk away nobody can just say
i had a fun time i made a shitload of
money now i'm out
everybody's got to be relevant and if
politics is relevant they're political
if this went the other way and no one
cared about politics she'd be still
talking about
you know eating her out in a mexican
restaurant or whatever the hell she
wrote books about
yeah she's talking about politics
nuggets that's
if politics wasn't relevant chelsea
would be riding seven mexican guys down
the street
on her way to a cinco de mayo
celebration the woman wants to be
relevant
she's i mean i don't know that she's
ever read a book or has any thoughts
about anything
yeah she just understands that racism is
bad congratulations
good job great job we're glad you've
come to this
and here comes someone right here a
beautiful young man right here good
looking audi i'm impressed
with the looks on the audience here
thank you man i'll say this this is some
of the
uh my people when they call in it's all
ski masks you can't see their faces are
wanted by the feds
this is kind of a first to us too it
must be a weird venn diagram of your
guys's fans that
interesting the podcast regular
listeners
the only question i have for you is
in relation to something that i'm
dealing with right now i'm trying to
find a better place to live
but i can't because my horrible [ __ ]
credit situation i owe so much money to
creditors because of chemotherapy
and i'm not going to [ __ ] pay even if
i do i'm just going to keep having these
delete
marks on my credit report so i'm
[Music]
number one let me say it was a little
irresponsible of you to get cancer
yeah i was a little irresponsible
especially don't see me going out and
getting cancer
i can't afford it especially during this
time yeah cancer is also going to do
i do want to say it's a luxury it's a
luxury here's here's
i'll be very serious for a minute you
can do credit repair and all that
[ __ ] i have to pay
up front for everything so if i get an
apartment i got to pay 12 months in
advance because
my credit sucks so i have to pay up
front
for everything i get because i put
myself in that position
but i work my ass off i'm doing good on
the podcast or whatever
but i mean you want to repair the credit
because that's
but the good if you could save a little
cash people might take if you have a bad
credit score you might take three months
up front now
right you want that cash and you might
be able to negotiate better so if it's
three thousand dollars a month you could
say look i'll give you 2 400 and i'll
pay you five months up front
so yeah also this is going to lead right
into our ad for bridge
credit solutions which is uh
a company that's uh that's fixing my
credit right now um
and they're great and i'll connect you
with the guys please no i legitimately
need it jj is awesome man
i gotta let you guys know that bridge
credit solutions
is what i'm talking about i have a
refinance
on my apartment which is in uh louisiana
and um and i was airbnb in it
and now i can't and i got to get that
refi but the bank won't give me that
refi
because i have some dings on me credit
yeah i got a couple of uh you know just
a couple of just made some poor choices
missed a payment you know missed two
payments actually
so i can't get the refinance right now
but that's where bridge
credit solutions is helping me
what i love about them is they are
backed with a hundred percent
money back guarantee for any items
that cannot be removed you'll you'll not
find that
anywhere in the credit repair industry
you know exactly what you're paying for
at the beginning of the repair
no open-ended monthly fees it's written
in the contract what is to be done
and how much you're paying you pay per
item
that's right you need something removed
you pay for that to be removed
now you will need to have bridge report
access prior to scheduling your audit
but that costs just one dollar and can
be found
on their website by simply clicking on
the services drop down bar
where you'll see bridge report access
you get the bridge credit report access
you schedule an appointment with bridge
credit solutions
and you're on your way to repairing your
credit fast
they also offer zero percent apr loans
business loans
financial counseling etc but
they do a great job i'm working with
them right now they're personable they
take communication
seriously go to
bridgecreditsolutions.com
theo that's bridge credit
solutions dot com slash
theo get your bridge report access and
start repairing your credit
now um what else did i want to talk
about nick do you remember anything else
we wanted to talk about
i mean oh i guess the
um i don't know we covered a lot of
stuff i covered a lot i've been talking
for a while nick yeah
hour and a half wow oh you're going to
space dinner tonight aren't you
i think so yeah i think so maybe i'm i'm
going to pretty sure
is it outside his birthday is it his
birthday yeah i didn't know it was his
birthday
yeah he just he didn't say i'm getting
del taco after this though i just need a
taco
oh just hold me over uh tucker carlson
uh new york times released his
address did they or i see i only i claim
that they were gonna i literally only
stopped from yours
they do [ __ ] like that they did it with
like i just get
you know listen man i don't watch tucker
i don't care sometimes he says something
i'm like that makes sense
sometimes he says something i'm like
that's wrong i love all these people
that are so committed to like
hating a guy or loving a guy i'm like
who
why i just watch the guy every now and
then i go yeah i don't think so
how did we get there though how do we
get where people
because i noticed sometimes i'll notice
i'll fall into it if i really let myself
yeah but then i notice i'm not an
activist right like
people crave uh there's a few things
about people they crave
drama they crave fights it's back to the
days of the roma coliseum oh yeah they
like to see combat
now there is no real combat right now so
a lot of people are sitting on a couch
and they're on the computer so the
combat is all internet it's all digital
they love that um i also think that
people
are just they want to be slaves people
want
to generally be in a group and to have
allies and then have another group that
they hate
yeah it's just what it is and it's like
i don't know what that is
somebody might be able to explain that
behavioral psychologist or somebody i
don't know people just
like having friends that they connect
with
and they get these friends by having the
same enemies and the same allies
so you can't look at a guy like tucker
carlson he's a human being
and then he might be wrong about things
um you look at him as an
enemy of you he's a direct enemy of you
um uh because he espouses a different
political ideology because you think
that
he's making life unsafe for people
because of what he believes
yeah and some of that might have some
some
some some relevance you know like i get
it if you're undocumented immigrant
you know obviously your opinion of uh
trump is probably very different than a
guy like me who has a luxury of being
like
hey i'm not getting deported right right
um
that doesn't mean every political
argument you're ever going to have
there's real
life consequences and real people are
going to be affected that doesn't mean
you can't
have a political argument about
immigration right does it mean you can't
talk about abortion
yeah some people think that the points
are in one lane that they have to
stay in that lane for everything yeah or
they think that if they can
you know yeah school shootings are
horrible i don't want them to happen i'm
for all kinds of kind of regulations
but just because people real people are
affected by something
i mean the reason we're talking about it
is because people are affected right the
reason it's an issue in general is
because people are affected
and if you shut down dialogue then what
are people supposed to do
so these emotional appeals that a lot of
people have on the left and the right
where they're just like
but what about that kids what about that
it's like yeah but how did we get here
how do we get to the kids in the cages
it's not having an immigration policy
it's not having any agreed upon policy
that's how we got here so we need
to figure out a way to have a policy
that makes sense yeah
yeah and there has to be it's also like
we always want everyone else to do
everything it's like
the government all of it is just society
it's just
the best we can do right right now right
it's like some people act like
every everything should be different
everything should be different if it was
supposed to be different
right now yeah it would be different
this is the best we can do
to have one of the best societies in the
world i wonder if sometimes my boomer
parents might make fun of all the time
but like sometimes my dad was right when
he was just like
like every time somebody bring up
politics my father would just be like
i can't get involved yeah it's really
the best thing he goes i just can't get
involved like
like he just like like there's a certain
level of like if you're gonna get in it
get in it run for something
yeah really get in there but we can't
have a society where every [ __ ] human
being is a cable news anchor yeah
we can't i can't be in line at starbucks
and and people are you know in a heated
political debate at eight o'clock in the
morning
we can't do it well it's unhealthy
there's more to life that's the other
thing about plastics dude
there's more to life go camping go fall
in love go
do something go read a book go love
someone yeah and it really
talking about it it gets so it's such an
addictive thing
and it's funny like the biggest
addiction
in the world right now really is uh
people consuming things that they like
like the news really media that they
know is bad for them
but they wake up and they go to it again
and again let's just do it
yeah let's just do it anyway and they
know it's been and it's a bro that is an
addiction
because they do it to feed something
inside of themselves
they do it because it's easier for you
to sit there and be angry
any of us and i don't mean someone but
all of us it's easier for us to sit
there and be angry than it is to take
action and make our lives better
a 100 percent i think this is an escape
and i think people escape into this
world instead of fixing the world that
is very close to them yeah
like yeah bob you know and it's hard
it's hard to remember sometimes but
but we try and think about that a lot in
here but yeah dude thanks so much man
thank you
tell me about your podcast too again tim
dillon's show it's on youtube and all
the other places you'll get it and uh
you know we put it out once a week that
we have a patreon if you like it so much
want an extra episode
we do an extra episode a week and that
is uh at the patreon.com
the tim dillon show yeah it's awesome
we're patreon subscribers to his aren't
we
yeah yeah so we're we have a lot of fun
and i enjoy it and uh
that's you know the future until you
know maybe forever but
have you thought about coming out with a
a different type of show at some point
do you start to think about that
absolutely because i get bored yeah
we'll get bored we'll do something we
get good at it
then we get bored and you have a co-host
right uh well i have a producer who
he chats sometimes yeah every now and
then he chats back
in and uh he chats every now and then
but for the most part he just sits there
they they're not there to pipe down yeah
hey pipe down yeah nick will sometimes
bring up his home state you know
constantly or something
every now and then rogue is going to
give jamie vernon death there
she shoot him a desk there like you want
to get your head kicked off
right now uh check out tim dillon's show
um i'll see you later tonight yeah thank
you so much for coming in
you bet i appreciate it now i'm just
floating
on the breeze and i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i
can feel it
but it's gonna take a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
that go on me
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
on the runaway train with a heavy load
of my
pants
and these wells that i've been riding on
they want something that they're damn
they're gone
just